la sphère patrick dils maintenant la
cour de révision va se prononcer cet
après-midi sur la condamnation de cet
homme de 31 ans condamné à la prison à
vie pour le meurtre de deux garçons en
1986 à montigny-lès-metz
pour bien comprendre cette affaire le
rappel des faits maintenant avec fanny
au vernis ces marches qui mènent à la
cour de révision
les parents de patrick dils les ont
gravi maints et maints de cet après midi
il espère que ce sera la dernière
après trois ans d'enquêté la cour de
révision doit trancher
il ya trois semaines l'avocat général
avait demandé l'organisation d'un
nouveau procès pour patrick dils après
14 ans d'attentats clamé son innocence
enfin c'est l'espoir de l'adq ont tort
cette fille en 1986 à montigny-lès-metz
patrick dils avoue le meurtre de deux
enfants puis se rétracte lorsqu'en 1989
il est condamné à la perpétuité
personne ne connaît encore l'existence
de francis heaulme
depuis la présence du tueur en série est
avéré sur les lieux le jour du crime
il travaillait dans la région il a même
menti sur son emploi du temps de
nouveaux éléments troublants susceptible
de semer le doute sur la culpabilité de
patrick dils est d'amener la révision de
son procès dans sa prison à toul
patrick dils attend la fin de 14 années
suspense